- Les images qui nou j j j j j s
rappellent les pires massacres.
La ville de 37 000ababitants a
été lourpupupupupupupupupupupupr
les forces russes, qui semblent
s'être défoulées sur des civils
innocents. Cette résidente a
cherché son mari pendant
sommairement enterré dans
le sous-sol d'un bâtiment.
(pleurs)
- "On lui a tiré uelelelelelelen
visage a été mutilé, il a été
torturé. Je l'ai reconnu grâce
à ses chaussures et
JONATHAN PEDNEAULT, chercheur,
Human Rights Watch
- C'est très clai a a a a a a aa
les mains attachées derrière
le dos et que ererersonne est
décédée d'une balle dans la
tête, ça s'apparente gravement
a une exéc
- Ces images fournies par
la présidence ukrainienne,
montrent Volodymyr Zelensk,,,,,,
par ces habitants qui recoivent
de l'aide alimen
- "Ce sont des crimes de
reconnus par le monde comme
un génocide." Une accusation
aussitôt réfutée par les Russes.
Qui dénoncent une mise
"avaient déjà quitté la ville le
31 mars". "Le maire de Boutcha
n'a rien rapporté de tel
ce jour-là, mais deux jo
en scène dans les rues"
- Or, ces images satellites
an q q q q q q q q q q q q q q s
jonchaient déjà les rues de
Boutcha il y a trois semaines.
Ce que confirme Human Rights
Watch.
documenté où on a pu confirmer
quatre exécutions sommaires le
4 mars par les forces russes.
Il est très clair qu'on voit
énormément d'incidents qui
a des crimes de guerre.
Ce Québécois était en Ukraine
pendannfnfnfnfnfnfnfnfnfnfnfnfn.
Human Rights Watch rapporte
sommaires aussi à Kharkiv,
Kiev et Tchernihivcececececececn
veut rappeler aux parties
lilililililits que la guerre dot
qui ont été universellement
acceptées depuis un siècle,iiiie
mondiale.
- Les alliés de l'OTAN ont tous
vivement dénoncé les massacres
de Boutcha.
président de la France
- On ne peut passeseseseseseser.
on doit avoir des sanctions
dissuasives, avec ce qui vient
de se passer lioioioioioioioioi,
il faut qu'on envoit très
clairement
qu'aujourd'hui, c'est notre
dignité collective, ce sont nos
valeurs nininininininininininint
que le Canada va donner plus
de mbububububububunal pénal
international pour enquêter
sur ces allégations de crimes
deLYLYLYLYLYLYLYLYLYLYLYLYLYLYLY
ministre des affaires étrangères
e e e e e e e c'est complètement
innaceptable, c'est choquant
et inhumain ce qui se passe h he
à Boutcha est scandaleux,
mais ce n'est pas un génocide."
rejettent toujours l'appel
des Ukrainiens pour
plus direct, sur le terrain.paps
isolé.
- "C'est du fascisme pur",dididt
de découvrir les corps de trois,
pa v v v v v v v v v v v v v v t
Ukrainiens."
"J'ai un message aux Européens,s
ne voulez que cela a
plus efficacement."
Ici Sara La